Tate has
really fascinating observations about
gender Dynamics I know this is going to
sound crazy if you're someone who's
never ingested his content besides like
the most Elation [ __ ] that comes out on
Tick Tock I was one of those same people
and I'd always hear people copying
please for him going no he makes some
really good points and and I'd go it
seems like he's just saying the wildest
ship possible that's also funny like
what are you talking about he also makes
good points right and then I saw him in
discussion with these women
and now I understand what they're saying
his really interesting observations
about gender Dynamics and the the
problem is I don't know if it's a
problem I'm projecting what I would want
if I was in his situation maybe he wants
this exact thing maybe he wants to be
talked about Non-Stop and he wants the
excitement and the chaos that goes along
with being one of these like incredibly
politicized figures
but
the problem is
the way that he delivers his information
and maybe this is because of the
algorithm it is indigestible to women
and it is candy to men
the people that actually could benefit
from a lot of things that he says women
are women but they'll never be able to
touch it because the way it's
communicated is for men and I know this
sounds crazy if you if you haven't
watched long-form conversations can you
give an example
he's just talking about like the the
importance of status that there was a
really good one status States
but no he was talking about a really
interesting thing about like with
Brittany Renner Brittany Renner has been
like very public about all the guys that
she's been with yeah right and he's
gonna he was talking about why this
would be very difficult with for a man
because even because when he's with you
he's competing with all the people that
he's that you've slept with and the
reality of she's [ __ ] all these NBA
players these like super rich Guys these
rappers and all these things the guy
that she settles with
might not be as rich as the NBA players
as famous as the as the rappers as
Talent as in him so he might always feel
insecure and if it's your job to make
your man feel like the king of the
household and he can't because he's
constantly competing with your past he's
always going to feel that insecurity and
then treat you based on that insecurity
and it's a really interesting argument
for the idea of having either a low body
count or just being quiet about your
body count it's one thing to [ __ ] a lot
of rappers and have a pass and do all
these things but you displaying it on
the internet writing a book about it
telling everybody puts you in a position
where you might be alone because there's
not going to be a guy that's going to
want to put up with that baggage just
just to to round out the point
regardless if you agree that or disagree
with it that information is probably
valuable to a lot of women growing up
today that are like
um running with the whole thought is a
personality identity yeah and sharing
all their exploits online and then
they've reached 30 and they're like why
am I alone and single and nobody wants
to put up with me
I I think that if
yeah he made and he did
it was like really insulting or
degrading to women it was just like a
really interesting observation about
gender Dynamics yes and and I'm sitting
there and I'm going wow like the the
people that would benefit the most from
this are not men because we know it we
feel these things innately maybe he can
package them in a way that we go oh
that's how I feel but we feel these
things already yeah the people that
would benefit from this are the women
that don't understand why men feel
certain ways about certain situations
why we don't want to know necessarily
about your past why I don't want to know
a single thing because I don't want to
start competing in my head with these
people that existed for you already
they'll never be able to digest that
because of how polarized he is and he
chose to be that polarized yeah yeah uh
The Genius of that I think and this is
where he can be so smart is rooting it
in a vulnerability which is true it's
based on our insecurity and when you
present it that way it's so much more
palatable and he can do that whenever he
wants to and we've always said this the
thing that separates him from everyone
else in that world is he can package his
points smarter than everybody else yeah
he's just the best at packaging it yep
and I personally think he doesn't mind
all the chaos in the same way that he
has the same superpower that Trump has
that I guess we say Jay Paul has where
it's like look I don't mind if you hate
me I understand as long as you are
talking about me I'm going to get where
I want to go the tricky thing is is once
he gets there is he going to want to
Pivot to more nuanced points which he's
clearly capable of making or or like
packaging them in this really like nice
vulnerable like holy [ __ ] we could all
learn something from this guy kind of
way or is he gonna be like well I got to
do what's made me get this famous but
let's stick with that he's a good
packaging for men though yeah like he's
not gonna really packaging it for all
people and I kind of I I don't I don't
want to interrupt you go make your point
thank you I guess I just look at all
Media or a lot of media like that where
like you know if you listen to like a
right-wing commentator there's a
probably some truth to what they're
saying in specific instances but they're
packaging for there but they're
packaging it to get views and make money
rather than to actually impact change
like if you're trying to hit the people
that need to hear it the most you try to
wrap it in a conversation that's
palatable to those people like I thought
that dude a manual acho yeah it's like
when he was doing like those
uncomfortable conversations like during
kova during like all the BLM stuff he
was making it to be like okay this is
going to be approachable for like white
people to listen to blah blah and he
wasn't trying to like make it vitriolic
just to like appease a black base to be
like okay let's make money it seemed
like he actually wanted it that's what
we did was turn your phones we
specifically did them in a way where
wouldn't alienate either side of the
people that felt away about this issue
but also spoke to the things that they
were about feeling it's really hard to
do yeah it's much harder it's way easier
to just fall into the comfort of the
people who already support you yeah the
unfortunate a part of that is that you
lose out in the people who actually need
the information it's like what I was
talking to Jordan Peterson about and I
was like my only issue Jordan with you
going with the daily wire is that the
people that that actually will benefit
from your information are the people who
would never consume something on the
daily wire which are the people who
might lean way more left they could
probably benefit from the things you're
saying and the way that you articulate
things and the way you present your
arguments they're really sound but just
having that label is going to make them
go oh Ben Shapiro right wing super
conservative I don't want anything to do
yeah so I agree with you in terms of my
first um
like the understanding of Tate was just
like the clips that went well he was
saying salacious [ __ ] and I was like oh
this guy's a piece of [ __ ] dude he's
like and like I was like this is
actually bad for relationships and like
men and women yeah and then hearing that
podcast is like okay some of your ideas
I I get it and he is right about
I wouldn't say a lot but like he is
right and so but then he like
packages it in the surface level way of
thinking that is like if a guy hears is
like yeah yeah and then for a woman just
like oh [ __ ] I just have to just deal
with it and like the type of things
he'll say is like you know if you're a
top G
I should be able to just sleep with
women and like you just have to take
that you have to and it's like in help
package these like the conclusions of it
were misguided yeah but the information
might have been somewhat true he's also
speaking from an emotional place so we
all know how we want the world to be
yeah but we're also limited by like
Primal emotions yeah of course right and
he's speaking to how a behavior that a
woman exhibits could make a man her
partner feel and then how he feels is
going to indicate how he behaves in that
relationship and that's important [ __ ]
because if you look at every one of
these female magazines why he acts like
this when why he pretends he's tired
when why he doesn't want to sleep it's a
bunch of women telling women how men act
and why they act and now you have a guy
doing it but he's doing it in a way
where no women will ever want to listen
when they could really benefit well at
that point let me ask you this that
point actual question how would women
receive that poorly would it just be I
don't have to deal with your insecurity
or what because to me more articulated I
thought you articulated the points
really well for women on that podcast
specifically because he was talking to
all women and that's what happens when
you Reaching Across the aisle you're
forced to sort of like compromise on
some of the crazy stuff to make it
approachable yeah but when you're just
in your own little Echo chamber you
don't have to do that when you have four
dudes that are gonna go just cheer you
on yeah that [ __ ] you go crazier and
like you just get and your emotions take
over and when the environment is created
so that you're supposed to dunk on these
girls like for example Tate on on fresh
and fit or whatever the environment is
hey dunk on these girls who aren't ready
or equipped for these arguments when
he's talking to those four girls who all
have thought about their arguments have
thought about their positions and have
thought about why they feel that way now
he has to become more nuanced he's going
to get pushback yeah it's not going to
be some thought who's thought about her
eyelashes all day yeah it's going to be
a girl who's sitting there going my life
is tough because of this and I need to
know why you saw Brittany kind of like
open up and like almost like ask for
advice yeah that was I saw that clip
actually and then I saw the Clementine
clip which was funny yeah and these are
happy but that clip was also interesting
is the girl who had Tate on
found him funny and I think that was
also disarming like you could tell she
had she's like let's have our fun you're
a fun guy or a funny guy and it I think
it also created an environment where
it's like hey we can all who's that the
Pearl Pearl but she's a big fan she's a
super fan I think but she's like red
pill girl oh she's a special girl yeah
like she's uh I think people would call
her like the tape but a girl oh okay
yeah okay which is like a very
interesting position to be in that's
almost like Candace Owens you know it's
a weird thing to compare to but in the
same way where like you yield power
because at least a guy can watch him be
like see a woman gets it because you
speak to the other side exactly where
white people can look at Candace and be
like see black people do okay be
annoying
so I had to put up just like a little
poll on my story
um just a a little excerpt from the
podcast and I ask people like how do you
feel about this and I just wanted to get
their responses it's so crazy how
different based on gender people like
what was the excerpt um it was about
like uh men just wanting a woman to like
I think either be agreeable or like less
pushback and less battling or whatever
the case is and it's like I would say
half the women who responded didn't even
take it in there just like takes a piece
of [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah they're not gonna
listen yeah the other half is like I
kind of see what he's saying but no guy
every guy would get bored with that
woman and would eventually leave and
what cheat on him it's not and all the
guys are like yeah
he's speaking facts and I'm like whoa
here's the thing about the agreeability
thing yeah
yeah it first of all it's great like
my wife got pissing me once I was
walking all the way home I was like man
I hope we hope we tonight
now now here's the problem
I hope we [ __ ] I was gonna hope dinner's
great I was like I hope we
win it was cold today I just need her to
be like yes it was and I'm like well for
this time of year
so so so I understand the idea of
agreeability
can we just get
on I promise I won't say anything else
about it okay so watch here's the thing
ready with agreeability the problem with
agreeability and then
never ever expressing your opinion at
least for someone like me is that I will
lose faith that that's how you actually
feel and I will feel more insecure that
you're just bending to what I want and
not being who you really are so now I
can't trust your reactions and I can't
trust your emotions if I can't trust
your emotions or reactions I feel more
insecure and I kind of feel like I can't
trust you period like so increases just
to give a bit more Nuance he actually
said he doesn't want to push over okay
like he wants somebody to
um have their own viewpoint but on
little things like
the temperature or whatever yeah he
right that [ __ ] right dog hey
bro hey how much that University
just feel like Hey we're leading like
trust us that we're leading Us in the
right direction and it's like if if
women just give you pushback every step
of the way it's like oh you don't trust
me yeah and that's how we feel women are
just like no I'm just voicing how I feel
or I'm voicing my opinion or whatever
the case is and it's like that's just I
just saw with the responses the clear
disconnect of that topic and then
sometimes women feel like if they don't
give
some pushback or some reaction they
don't have a voice at all
and
when you feel like you have a voice at
all sometimes you amplify your voice
about everything to make sure that you
have a voice to you yeah right so now
we're in this situation where it's truly
just ego a man's ego going I want to
feel like I'm the man of the house and a
woman's ego well I don't want to feel
like I'm nothing in the house I feel
like a typical 50s woman with no opinion
yeah exactly and this is where I think
you get the pushback uh towards feminism
at least from like the Redfield space
which is like they're gonna go feminism
has made you think that you have to have
an opinion about everything and give
[ __ ] and if not you're getting walked
over in your house and it's like yet the
most extreme version of that but the
opposite is you're just sitting there
like a little Dove quietly not saying a
single thing and now your man is feeling
insecure are you even happy yeah do you
like like how often you want to go get
somebody sure what do you want I don't
care we don't know what that is what do
you want I don't know that's not what
you want at all that's the worst yeah
yeah I like it when my girl is sure
about the things that she if it makes me
feel confident when my girl's sure about
the things that she likes yeah because I
know when she's happy about something
it's real yeah I need to be able to
trust your emotions I need that so
that's the the other the problem with
the Other Extreme which is like the red
pill extreme is you could create a
person where you can't trust anything
but they say if you can't trust anything
they say that's no foundation for a
relationship
but yeah I think it's also on the man to
open up the conversation like if you are
quote unquote leading in your
relationship yeah and I don't think
every relationship needs to follow the
same exact thing necessarily but if you
are in relationship with the guys
leading and the girl is sort of like in
a I guess I don't know like she's
following your leadership you need to
open up that space and be like hey how
do you actually feel about this and
create an environment where she's able
to talk freely yeah yeah like if you've
created it where you don't like listen
to her opinion or if she voices
something and you just like shut it down
that's on you for creating a hostile
environment for her to share what she
thinks and if she raises her opinion and
you can't tell her why and this is why I
think long long term this is the best
move for us that's on you you're giving
if you can't communicate what you think
your vision is and why it's that way and
why you're gonna get there with this
route you probably don't deserve to have
it but he was saying uh he doesn't want
to always have to
[Laughter]
but this is the power of communication
yeah it's like if his career was built
on only going on female podcasts
explaining these principles to them
there's a different version of Andrew
Tate I don't know if it touches many
guys that's yeah I don't know if it does
as many guys I don't know if it's as big
of a version and it might not be and it
might not make the views it might not do
it's like even with the episode that
that Pearl put out
I think the name of the episode is Tate
destroys feminists exclamation point
yeah it's just like and I get it you're
tapping to the algorithm we all tap into
the algorithm the problem with that is
you're isolating the people that
actually would benefit from the message
through that algorithmic cocoon that's
great it's just every dude that just
wants to see feminist owns clicking that
instead of a few women they're like oh
wait a minute is that why my boyfriend
or my husband reacts with such
insecurity when I do that yeah oh [ __ ]
and just because they do doesn't make it
right but at least you know why they
have that impulse that's really
important it's not necessarily you it
should bake in our DNA from [ __ ]
millions of years of evolution yeah I
guess it's also the intention of the
message like he might be packaging it
incidentally the way that he is because
he's just going based off how he feels
but if the intention of it is like
empathy like with this pretty render
thing I haven't seen the clip but if the
feeling is like oh let me actually help
you I think the message is interpreted
completely differently the intention is
let me dunk you first thing he says I'm
pretty sure is you're right there is a
double standard like he doesn't he's
unfair he says it's unfair which is even
more like but he doesn't say like [ __ ]
you yes unfair he's like no you're right
you're right to feel this it is unfair
here's why we think it's unfair yeah and
it's like oh that but again he's so
funny and so good at creating gravity
and the best way to do that is by being
funny and being salacious yeah I think
the reason he rose like a comet is I
gotta be salacious and I can back it up
with comedy and packaging so the
question I have is if you're making so
much money from Hustler's University
if you're
which he is and if you're famous and
people love you and people are into what
you're doing you're getting a deal I
imagine from Rumble you're making tons
of money over there
why even Dabble
in the [ __ ] that could get you arrested
like you are now why even still continue
to do that I think that I think it is
old [ __ ] so this is coming from like
years ago I thought this was done from a
few months ago no I think he like once
Hustlers University blew up like he
stopped all the sex yeah I don't know if
that's the case but I think the
allegation I mean the allegation the
first one April 22nd I think or whatever
April 2022 they got him arrested a girl
flew out from America and then I think
her parents called the U.S embassy like
she's for whatever reason they reported
him but that's when it started and I
don't know I think allegations are from
still around that time I think because I
think they've been investigating him for
nine months I could be wrong on this but
he just talks about like the sex hotline
like that was something he used to do
yeah it doesn't seem like he still does
it seems like it's mostly money stuff
like I'm assuming he's getting paid all
through the internet making all his
money through Hustler's University
getting paid in the United States
technically blah blah blah and like
shuffled some numbers around and then
now the Romanian IRS is going for him
yeah this is what I'm saying I mean
that's who always gets you back I mean
isn't that uh what's his face
yeah you get everybody who does the at
the you know yeah you get all the mafia
dudes with the money [ __ ] because
they're too insulated you're not gonna
get in with the murders you're not going
to get them maybe the racketeering a
little bit I guess Rico is the charge
that they use now to do it I don't know
if they even have Rico and Romania what
do you think of the way that Tate's
framing all these things that are
happening so like I saw him saying a
bunch where he's like okay look they
canceled me once and I know that I'm
that's bad and I'm intimidated by that
because you get three lives they cancel
you and then they put you in jail and
then they try to kill you and I've
already lost one of my lives and he said
this like a few months ago and I just I
want to let you know I will not kill
myself I am not yeah I mean to me I
think it's brilliant marketing right
which is you already know that there's
an investigation going on in you
obviously if he's as big as he is if
he's the top G in Romania he has people
in the probably the police department or
their version of the FBI or whatever the
[ __ ] it is who are like yo there's an
ongoing investigation about you you know
they're eventually going to go back in
jail so of course go on all these
platforms and then say the Matrix is
coming for me is it the Matrix or is it
the [ __ ] police that have said
hey we're building this case against you
you know what else to that point I was
when I was like Tori going listen The
Matrix is after me I mean I know I shot
this woman in the foot but the Matrix is
conspiring to put me in prison yeah uh I
was looking for that and Greta
Thunderbird tweet to send you guys and I
was looking at his Twitter and I don't
know if he's always tweeted like this
but it seemed like it was a lot of like
super red pill [ __ ] like um if you wore
a mask I stopped being your friends if
you got the vax we stopped being friends
you're a follower and it was like super
speaking to that group of people that if
you know you might get arrested they're
still going to ride with you and you can
say it's a conspiracy and it's the
Matrix and this group of people is
completely unbelieving it seemed like it
was shifting that way because he might
have known some smoke was coming and
maybe that's why he went at Greta
actually in the long term he's like look
let me go at this global warming let me
go at the super left I mean Super left
to get the super right to like me so if
when I get arrested I can say it's all
conspiracy and they're going to ride
with me maybe yeah I mean it's classic
storytelling yeah it's a classic hero's
journey yeah like an individual you know
sacrifices himself to you know protect a
group from a uh what is it a
like a tyrannical leader that's abusing
their power selfishly and uh yeah you
could just find it over and over in
every single story at least Western
stories does he does he stay in prison
you think I think he gets convicted or
like with money charges there's gonna be
like tax evasion pay the fine I imagine
with a guy who makes money
internationally is incredibly easy to
pin tax evasion yeah especially if
you're making money through crypto [ __ ]
I mean I think he was making some money
through crypto somebody you're making
money through it yeah